salut tout le monde vous retrouvez une
équipe d'envergure heureuse tout
simplement parce qu'on est complètement
drogué de cette march madness qui a
débuté depuis quatre jours j'exclus les
matches aux tours préliminaires du
premier tour quatre jours de folie et
forcément des performances de prospects
à évaluer pour nous donc on va s'y
mettre
suite c'est un nouvel épisode et ça
commence juste après le générique
[Musique]
la joyeuse équipe ce soir est composée
de ben
bonjour ben tu es heureux tu es drogués
je suis je suis sous de march madness
d'ailleurs à l'année -10 à sion texter
samedi soir de ce que j'étais saoul de
la performance de johnny jude zain
unique usine l'uci et les gt sens chez
moi
les bénéfices de l année là donc saluer
l'excellent tout le monde moi je suis
j'en peux plus tu te poses de 2 3 jours
fait du bien oui voilà un petit break
avant de reprendre donc la parution donc
mercredi langis ce le mardi soir et les
matchs reprennent samedi les matchs de
march madness samedi dimanche lundi
mardi pour les matches du sweet sixteen
et de l'élite ait donc l'équivalent si
vous voulez thiem de finale aller des
quarts de finale et enfin on ne pouvait
pas évidemment enregistré un peu de
casse march madness 101 membres de la
ceni dans l'équipe de midnight en campus
et c'est donc hugo qui est avec nous à
lugos salut alex salut à tous
pour ceux qui connaissent la star de
youtube alan guillou vous étiez apparus
ensemble dans une vidéo chez first ribul
fin de la dernière avant plus sournois
saluer c'est vrai qu'on avait parlé de
peyton twitter et déjà beaucoup donné
hugo j'ai une chance que tu es un peu
spécialisé dans les équipes de l'ouest
du côté de militants comme passe c'est
ça moi j'ai une préférence une attirance
particulière pour une équipe qui réussit
assez bien en puisque c'est haussier
je suis pas du tout c'est lui aussi
l'impôt fait exprès en plus loin si donc
qui est l'équipe d'evans mobley d'un
billet vous plaît et d'autres prospects
un peu un peu moins intéressant pour le
monde
robin dire et qui est toujours en course
on vous invite
si vous suivez ce podcast à avoir à peu
près le bracket sous les yeux en tout
cas les oppositions à venir même si je
vais tâcher de le rappeler le plus
souvent possible
le but de ce podcast c'est tout
simplement de chat et tous les joueurs
qui nous ont plutôt impressionné ou ont
fait monter leur cote peut-être pendant
ces premiers matchs de march madness
même si évidemment sur deux matches se
passe quand on regarde toute l'année
mais c'est toujours important de voir
comment les joueurs se comportent dans
les grands moments
hugo tué l'invité honneur à toi qui tu
as bien qu'ils tuent a apprécié en fait
quelle performance tu vas
particulièrement apprécié quelle
performance a surpris alors outre la
performance des vins de mowgli non donc
je n'aurais pas parlé parce que je ne
manquerai forcément d'objectivité
je vais commencer par un joueur que don
baynes à un peu un peu parler de johnny
je rajouterais des petits des petits
bruits pendant le montage du j'ai besoin
d'une courte présentation puisque
évidemment on peut pas estimer que tout
le monde connaît les joueurs dont on va
parler donc à chaque fois on va décrire
le joueur en quelques mots johnny
douzaine qui s hugo alors johnny de zinc
d'abord c'était un grand espoir l'année
dernière à kentucky et comme pas
beaucoup de guar de kentucky il était
très mal utilisé par john calipari donc
cette année il a transféré est plutôt
plutôt très bien à ucla et c'est un
arrière qui est un super shooteur un
joueur que qui enfin qui me régale
personnellement qui est capable de
shooter à mi-distance à trois points et
qui je pense pour le cours à un freeroll
en biais et en tout cas je l'espère
parce que c'est vraiment un joueur qui
est très très élégant vont jouer en tout
cas c'est vrai qu'il est très élégant
avoir joué belle
est-ce que c'est déjà pour ça que tu
nous l'avait cité en tout début de
saison dernière comme ton ton petit
chouchou s'était pas bien passé à
kentucky mais un mètre 98 95 kg donc 6x
pour les des américains
sa capacité à mettre des points ce qui
est intéressante
le laser de los angeles bélie de tous
ces feuilles samedi soir il était
magnifique
il a montré beaucoup sa polyvalence au
tir il est sorti et a tiré en sortie
d'écran il le tire et en catch and shoot
il est serrée pour l'heure il est serré
ce que j'ai à perdre sidestep beaucoup
il a peut-être trois ou quatre fois
pendant la soirée soit c'est quelque
chose que j'aime beaucoup beaucoup chez
mes prospects c1 c'est un réflexe qui
est très utile à un billet mis à montrer
du flair sans ballon si il était ce un
joueur est devenu 12 ans beaucoup qui
pour une grande explosion mais qui est
prêt gracieux qui sait bouger sur le
terrain il était il était de toute
beauté
est ce que tu as vu des choses de ti
sans surprise par rapport aux joueurs
que tu avais peut-être quitté il ya
quelques semaines quelques mois ou du
côté de kentucky en tout cas du joueur
que tu t'attendais à voir ce qu'il ya
des choses qui se font dire ah oui
peut-être que ce sera un peu mieux que
prévu encore en vie des civils sont les
sons ligne je pensais pas qu'il allait
avoir autant et à trois points de très
loin et l'on parle pas d'un trois points
de pareils je croyais pas qui est qui
avait justement un arsenal ou tire aussi
complet ce qui est vraiment très
important pour un look trendy
c'est ça s'étire en sortie d'écran
chicchi termes tu vraiment beaucoup plus
qui beaucoup le plus beaucoup plus
propre ayew s'ils allaient me aux séries
et une école qui est réputé pour son
propre bien d'enseignement et je vais
donner la parole à un âne mais je veux
quelque chose
j'aimerais qu'on parle des cheveux du
meneur a dû aussi à les tiger-cats beau
c'est vraiment terrorisant l'on dirait
qu'il a une âme il ya effectivement et
ça n'empêche pas d'être un joueur assez
agréable à voir jouer ce genre de petits
bonheurs voit quasiment jamais entre ou
d'une c'est toujours assez absolue
malien roellinger plaide plutôt pour
aller prendre le s'amène en jeep élite
probablement je vais faire appel à toi
pour ça que tempérer les ardeurs de
baisse est-ce que tout pour toi johnny
zeng là d'un coup évidemment il a fait
toute une saison où il a shooté à à 35%
à 3 points sur 6 tentatives ce qui est
plutôt honorable et surtout 91% safran
très honorable même plus qu'on aura
d'excellents est ce que pour toi il ya
un profil nba
nous avons en fait je les sais pas que
je vais tempéré mais c'est qu'en fait
c'est que la continuité de sa saison en
fait sur investissement belle équipe de
ucla qui joue bien au large des
shooteurs et puis zhejiang et dans ce
rôle là mais que sinon dans une drôle à
mi-distance aussi on l'a vu contre
content de vivre et où il est capable de
poser à poser le ballon au sol de faire
deux trois dribbles et et je pense qu'en
fait c'est un scoreur de ben quoi ça
peut être un score de van dans le monde
problème vient des grands mais si je
pense pas que c'est un actif en à peine
plus plus n'est-ce pas un joueur je
pense qu est ce qui peut être totalement
négatif donc moi je pense qu'il ya
s'était alors qu'on avait sur les radars
tu seras tu sors de kentucky et tutut on
a plus de dix points par match sur un
pack toile et en tant que sophomore en
shootant à 91% dans ces camps c'est sûr
qu'au dessus donc en fait c'est curieux
c'est une confirmation sur les deux
matchs pour les gens je pense qu'il ya
pas eu la chance de voir le ciel
absolument c'est une équipe sexy avoir
joué et que vous conseille vous oblige
un match tu sais elle est à la base un
ça va être une au moins une orgie
offensive est probablement un match de
très très haut niveau puisque ces deux
équipes qui non seulement shoot et c'est
donc c'est plaisant et du riz mais c'est
aussi deux équipes qui jouent vraiment
juste
ou pas ce qui est très intéressant ça
partage la balle les gens vont peut-être
faire la comparaison 10 ha ça sort de
cannes tim à l'utiliser gros shooteur
nananan tiger heroes pourquoi ils
réussirent m - bien que tiger heroes en
nba
je pense que même si ça peut paraître un
peu ça peut pas pas être pas grand mais
je pense que tiger heroes était quand
même un joueur plus athlétique john is
using là où johnny zeng est par contre
comment comment dire un peu plus
volontaires j'irai notamment au rebond
c'est un joueur qui qui pour un arriéré
qu'apple prendre beaucoup de rebonds
c'est d'ailleurs une de ses grandes
qualités quand il sortait du coup on
tournait presque à un offre bon moyen
donc c'est un domaine où je pense qu'il
veut rendre de fiers services à la
franchise qui le droit fera mais oui par
rapport à ta une horrible bien on va
dire un déficit est pathétique qui est
comme une autre peine peut-être une
différence de 2 tire aussi way we fall à
la taille zéro il ya des petits bras
donc ta sont vraiment très compacte
lorsqu'il tuait et papa être avec le
tabac c'est une grosse révélation avec
tagro c'est qu'on lui a donné la balle à
ami johnny jude zain on n'est pas trop
sûr si capable de faire ça ou non et
puis entre unis mais à 35% entrepont
carrière ce qui est bien et ce qui est
pas fou dans la moyenne
oui voilà ce qui est à 90% ne
contrebalance tout ça alan c'est à toi
de me donner de toute ta petite bonne
surprise ou en jouant dont tu veux
parler tout simplement donc et encore là
ou pas on perd des joueurs de bons
matches épiques issouf 8-3 trois choix
donc qui s'est fait éliminer très mal
parce qu'on en reparlera si ce président
à la drogue donc on va passer
moi j'avais envie de parler de ben je
crois que mon chouchou de la drogue
jamie robinson r ah ah les plaisirs je
sais pas trop je sais bien faire voir du
patron mais surtout en fait c'est un peu
drôle parce que j'ai l'impression que et
on en parlait toujours ensemble quand on
essaie d un peu trouver des équipes qui
pouvaient se faire au 7 au premier tour
on disait à villanova sont perdus
colling ils ont perdu gillespie c'est
pas non plus la meilleure équipe de
villa doit de ces dernières années
peut-être qu'ils pourraient sortir chez
plus petits jours pour vivre un amour
outre-rhin
ouais c'est ça winthrop cette étude un
peu une une équipe analyse d'analytique
darling de nba twitter qui textent un
peu une équipe qui pouvait vraiment
faire du tri une très belle perf face à
face à la villa noailles et basse emmène
sans meneur enfin sans qu'ils aient spi
moi j'ai trouvé robinson earl incroyable
sur les deux bras qu une incroyable
vraiment dans la roja sur pick'n pay
normal profite là non pour ceux qui ont
passé un poste c'est un poste 4-5 donc
c'est un genre café tim aux essais chez
déchets les plus jeunes
quand quand les gens les américains font
médaille d'or au film 'le 19 heures tous
les quelques nigam evans meublé
halliburton tout ça le poste 4
titulaires c'est lui jerome robbins
honneur les banques ni dans sa deuxième
année à villa noir s'il joue 5
il ya un petit plus la taille d'un 4
mais on sait que le post catrice plus
trop beaucoup - nba et donc c'est un
joueur qui joue simple il prend des
rebonds reposer écran qui est une belle
mécanique de tir qui finissait pas mal
sur pick and pop et qui est un défenseur
assez intelligent pas un énorme athlète
mais qui se place très bien et qui qui
montre de plus en plus de talents
offensifs à la passe notamment
c'est ce qui m'a le plus impressionné
c'est cette voie et sur la fin de saison
déjà
ça s'est su puis c'est surtout vu le
match que j'ai pu voir le match de
deuxième tour de vis la drogue est donc
vraiment un super impressionné par sa
dernier dernière il avait détesté on
savait pas trop de têtes tester un peu
les eaux de la draft qui étaient venus
pour une deuxième saison
et pour moi c'est un des mots c'est un
des meilleurs joueurs au le voir en
restant dû tourner au lycée un peu tout
faire il sait rien faire d'excès l'amant
bien et c'est pour ça qu'on allait mal à
l'évaluer à la draft
si l'on résumé exactement il ferait rien
délai de douze coureurs
spécialité potentiel de timba cup c'est
un peu problématique mais en fait il est
jamais vraiment négatif secteur ça aussi
c'est une qualité hugo est ce que tu as
quelque chose à nous dire sur gérer maya
robinson et religieuse une équipe de
l'est via nova ces finales fille
reconnaissant tout bien sûr aux singes
très content déjà que cal n en ai parlé
parce que c'est un joueur que j'ai adoré
depuis ses débuts revient à novo j'en
avais même parlé dans cet été dans un
article sur mes sophomore à suivre c'est
un joueur que le monde
j'aime beaucoup voient comme un avis en
fait un joueur complet qui a faim qui
est je pense la vraie raison du succès
de la nova d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote on
faisait partie selon mina tonnes kempès
de ceux qui avaient donné une trois
vainqueurs aussi donc on prend notre
notre l1 comme disent les chinois en
bronze
nous on mange notre pain noir tout ça
ouais c'est un très bon joueur vraiment
complet qui sera un très bon acteur je
pense qu'il sera un très bon le théorème
billets qui est capable de faire
beaucoup de choses sur le terrain de
défendre de se défendre sur des sur les
post 4 je pense qu'ils qui sera un peu
un peu léger pour switcher sur les
arrières un peu ample un papa c'est bon
la défense imants pour switcher sur les
arrières mais il ya quand même une vraie
il ya quelque chose chez jour
directement quelque chose due
moi ce que j'aime je suis juge et partie
là dans l'histoire vu que alan m'a déjà
dénoncé en tant que fan que de jr
mais ce que j'ai ainsi tiré du cerveau
en fait c'est bête pas raison mais c'est
évident quand on regarde les commerces
et séjours allant jouer et ils prennent
des phénomènes physiques les sculpte
défensive moi j'ai promis son dernier
match de la ronde des 32 noms mais je
n'ai vu
j'ai vu souvent quand même parce que je
garde quand même sur le big east puis je
vous coup sa défensive
j'aime beaucoup sa capacité à se
déplacer en défense et ils sont nés sont
cuites
c'est beaucoup plus selon moi c'est ça
sa carte de visite là c'est qu'il est
polyvalent 5 qui qui est un bon qui est
bon défenseur sur le wiki qui peut qui
sait bien faire un peu tout ça un peu à
la jaa pas la même position dans une
rotation et c'est un homme qui porte une
boucle en termes d'efficacité sociale
absolument donc qu'ils regardent et
vilanova si vous voulez voir du beau
basket ball il aura pas de problème
galloway l'or lors du sweet sixteen ça
devrait être tout monplaisant également
alors que je cède aucun des leurs mais
je suis capable donc longtemps qu'ils
pourront ensuite massatois mais après
johnny douzaine gmail un robinson r qui
de qui veux tu parlais par la prochaine
est-ce que vous avez vu d'avion contre
ce concert c'était absolument incroyable
c'était une performance terrifiante du
jeune joueur et un je ne sais si belle
joie sur seniors non moins les t-shirts
juniors c'est plus simple vous comptez
drop entre ham et wigan
il est hélas un rythme absolument
incroyables sur le terrain pour un
meneur au prochain niveau flair pour la
passe une vision du jeu ils défendent
souvent galilée avec lui et lui ai
suggéré de battre heurts ont fait la
vidéo a trahi je crois qu'ils
s'appellent le joueur et lui ont pourri
la vie toute la soirée c'était c'était
une performance pour moi qui j'ai vu
quelques fois berlin cette saison pour
beaucoup
mais c'est une performance qui m'a
vraiment ouvert les yeux moi je débats
avec moi même de le placer contre de
placer devant gerald butler ou dans mon
prochain épaules parce que c'est un
joueur qui est pris pour lundi
c'est le droit qui va ramener des
résultats immédiatement une vieille je
suis je suis devenu très fan c'est toi
alex nous avons ouvert les yeux sur lui
mais je suis maintenant je comprends
qu'elle ait dit en premier je sais plus
à qui je peux être cru qu'ils avaient
dit que le préfet ce cas d'accord lors
du podcast qu'on a consacré à jared
butler c'est évidemment la vienne
richesse donc un joueur de baylor je
suis rapidement profil mais c'est quoi
en 90 suis pas les mensurations et est
très dense
un peu moins de 90 même très très dense
92 kg a été happée à auburn il a
transféré à baylor douce et ça libe
c'est red shirt junior théoriquement il
lui resterait encore un nom mais il est
déjà le brut déjà l'âge d'un senior est
alors moi ce qui me perturbe c'est qu'il
shoote à 68% lancer de franco je
n'arrive pas à comprendre alors qu'il
est excellent à troupeau mais sinon tous
les voyants sont au vert
ok j'ai quelqu'un qui défie je pense
qu'il a une énorme en terme de son dieu
allan poe vous avez envoie à dire sur le
web à moi pour ma part déjà sur le match
c'est vrai que quand on voit un mec des
points mitchell 45
et en plus avec la façon bas avec la
façon avec laquelle est à jouer c'est
vrai que c'était donovan michel 2.0
enfin dans le moment ça s'est même
demandé si c'était pas frères cousins
quelque chose n'allait pas du tout donc
bon il se trouve c'est un total hasard
total mais va c'est un joueur que moi
j'ai pas énormément suivirent saison de
baylor parce que
simplement parce que je suis pas pas
ultra fan je dois être un des seuls
d'ailleurs un peu de fans leur style de
jeu
mais enfin c'est un joueur que j'avais
j'ai quand même une chance voir jouer
j'ai repéré j'adore son passé comme si
pathétique notamment son premier pas je
traiterai un film et c'est un joueur qui
a un gros coeur et qui est un groupe
anti capable de répéter beaucoup
d'action haute intensité donc je pense
que wayne mieux singh comme belmadi les
prébendes et vivent à l'aller ce que il
a fait monter sa cote des vieilles
mitchell parce que j'en identifie pas
beaucoup qui la font vraiment monter
mais là je me dis s'il domine encore
villanova qui place colette de plus en
plus clairement c'est quand même lui le
le coeur de cette attaque dès lors je
pense que je pense que l'on peut
attendre peut-être qu'ils qu'ils fassent
peut-être si dans l'oeil des gens je
pense que l'on a vu des scouts il est
pour moi il est assez haut mais la
veille du grand public peut-être qui est
une grosse performance contre 101
guardian a déjà eu au mcdo championnat
de la big toile tu me mentionnait des
bonne possession contre kei melhem on a
plus parlé du fait que kate a défoncé
baylor dans la deuxième mi temps c'est
que la deuxième défaite de et leur
assure la saison je crois ou la
troisième mais donc c'est un peu passé
sous le sous le dessous dessous sur tout
le monde mais en fait c'est un vrai bon
match défensif sur ce qui est pour moi
le meilleur joueur de l'année
donc non je pense qu'en fait ça peut
très bien bien haute
moi c'est un peu là là son rôle offensif
puis c'est de voir je pense que ce alors
que pourra défendre mais en nba si tu
peux si tu te tires pas ici tu t'es un
peu négatif et en faisant des choix
ballot moi c'est un peu compliqué sur
des bases d'ailleurs voir beaucoup de
minutes et voilà un bond de 30 à leur
propos mais pour tâche de lancer franc
et un petit peu problématique comme tu
l'as dit il fait pas mal de passes
décisives même temps c'est pas non plus
lui le talent que celui de
décisionnaires principal dans le
triangle à trois ans des 3 words
donc je faudrait que je vois plus plus
de deux films de lui quand il est balle
en main mais je pense qu'il ya quand
même une belle cote l'aide qui devrait
finir dans tous les top 25 on va dire
effectivement donc un joueur à suivre
des lieux de mitchell et vous pourrez
sans doute observer des possessions dans
du match 7 vila nova de mitchell face à
robin s'énerve 6l switch côté viennent
outre donc ça pourrait être relativement
ternes
alors là c'est maintenant c'est la libre
antenne je veux dire vous en avez cité
un chacun principal est ce que vous avez
d'autres joueurs a incité pays moi j'ai
votre joie est absolument je ne manque
jamais d'idées
j'ai regardé les deux matches de
michigan frensois défensivement on parle
d'un joueur c'est au niveau collégial
qui est crucial et d'un joueur que je ne
croyais pas qu'ils allaient pouvoir
avoir les 7,6 pour défendre
je ne suis plus sûre de ce qu'elle
avance
il ya un potentiel de plaute l'heure
assez complet chez françois va faire
monter sa cote très très haut peut-être
pas aussi haut que keven encore neil
burger affirmé mini premier dauphin
soignants je serais pas surpris il est
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup en
avant sur son frère kevin o'connor donc
le journaliste de ringer qui a placé
friends liner ne vienne ce qui est connu
comme un indice intéressant donc le
frère de mots wagner qui effectivement
défend capable de switcher ok ça c'est
bien parce qu'il est quand même très
très faim est très très faim il est pas
très explosif non plus il shoote pas mal
pas encore allé énormément de régularité
mais ça chauffe gamme très bien et je
crois que j'ai fait le résumé on en
reparlera de france d'haguenau je pense
qu'on pourra lui consacrer carrément un
épisode de dommages donc forcément
s'attarder là dessus
il va affronter ce calibre
dimanche prochain donc ça va être
vraiment la confrontation va être une
bonne chance de dégommer chute ni chien
c'est aussi sortir compter sur le sun
défoncé donc je vous relance pas sûr
france daguenière à la nourrit gauche
demande de citer une autre personne
prospecte et après on passera aux
questions des députés 06 13 duarte way
vas-y fais moi un petit profil rapidos
bon j'avais été invité il ya deux
semaines dans un podcast que je salue
pour présenter envergure d des fans doc
est 6eme demandeurs potentiels role
players de photos et j'avais des crises
dureté ou par henry je reste toujours ce
soir on aurait tout mais on n'a pas pu
trop pu le voir parce qu'ils ont perdu
leur match contre lui aussi là où je
comprends toujours pas comment ils ont
pu perdre deux matchs pour être honnête
je vais jamais que les gens les voient
la fin de match ce con tu prends un de
plus 100 à 2 secondes de la fin c'est
que tu fais là faute c'est si je vous
comprends pas bref mais donc restée
forte le dominicain me dominicain me
québécois bénitier web sur l'ailier
lelia temps plein et un peu à tout faire
dorer gourdon cacapa joue son premier
match entier tout simple déçu c'était
contre vie si oui est lâchement
messieurs après ils ont perdu ils ont
pas ils ont battu ayo à une orgie
offensive de début d'après midi du lundi
où ça ne défendent n est pas un gramme
et c1
j'adore le profil c'est un jeu pensé un
jour qui peut pas ses dribbles et shooté
à mon niveau il comptait grossir il est
très intelligent de savoir qui est passé
par le juke au café deux rondes locaux
et deux en or even donc il est mûr il
est mature il a 23 ans maintenant donc
moi je viens bientôt plein cap - bientôt
24 donc les îles et agit un peu comme
grands thrillers l'an passé qui était
très années pour ça qu'il est jeune ou
d'un homme de 46 points
dieu en thriller je suis déçu de ne pas
le voir sur terre et voilà donc risque
de heurter un un vrai bon joueur en plus
parce qu'ils vont jouer contre 8 voici
ce que les gens vont le regarder
bon je crois qu'il est super beau avoir
joué sous serre smooth dans une équipe
d'oregon super cool aussi avec ouvrir
louis richardson lequel y analyse de
l'horrible et puis une
et puis d'autres d'autres profils assez
intéressant lg figueroa rhône estrada
pas mal de latinos dans cette équipe ça
joue toujours bien et puis vous verrez
de chart's et effectivement été un peu
blessé cette année là il revient au
meilleur moment tête il a même si un
petit mot du go quand même qui est
spécialiste de la west coast nous rigole
ça joue bien crise duarte et ça a été
bon toute la saison
ouais c'est elles ont le goût tugay de
vori bonne pré saison et c'est à la
commande est la pierre angulaire du
système de de notre ami john hartman
essai de l'homme qui a permis aux
régates de faire une si belle saison et
peut aussi arriver ensuite sixtine même
si robben va perdre au prochain tour en
juin dans ce jeu désolé on tue aussi
mais lui aussi a été très impressionnant
contre comme ça ce donc le voici deux
ehpad mollet et à zahia mobile et dont
on à une question après le deuxième
choix du go alors moi je vais présenter
un joueur que j'adore également
sequencing rhymes de houston oui alors
il faut savoir que ce mec je le
détestais quand il a transféré au kansas
parce que déjà parce qu'il ya eu droit
de jouer comme ça sans raison sans s'en
passer sur le bon alors on explique
normalement il y avoir une année sur le
banc quand tu changes d'université ce
qui est de moins en moins le cas pour ça
premièrement ça faisait que je n'aimais
pas trop cette homme en plus le fait
qu'ils aient choisi kansas ça c'est
encore plus beau on estime mais
finalement houston cg découvrir la
beauté vrai beau joueur de basket assez
complet capable enfin d'abord très bon
shooteur qui tourne je pense à plus de
40% trois points je serais pas étonné
j'ai pas les stats et sous les yeux et
je vais te dire il doit pas être loin
des 40% en carrière
mais cette année à 40 de ses 140 dans
tatie donc c'est très très correct en
plus cette année à son jeu je trouve
qu'il a beaucoup progressé dans dans le
plein et king c'est devenu un vrai bon
facilitateur de jeu et je pense que même
si les juniors je suis prêt à tenter de
paris en au premier tour de la prochaine
draft leçons sans hésiter si évidemment
il
il est présent intéressant choix car
elle n'était pas trop d'accord une
chance qu'il a une magnifique mécanique
de tir mais que dans tout le reste il
allait
je le trouve terrorisé en fait je trouve
terrorisés dans des choix qui doit faire
il a beaucoup baissé son taux d'intérêt
ceci dit ça ça va bien ça va beaucoup
mais je leur en fait c'est je trouve
souvent terrorisé quand il a la balle
mais je n'ai pas très en confiance mais
par contre sa mécanique de tir est l'une
des plus belles que je trouve du pays et
pour ingénierie là il est pas si vieux
que ça il à même pas 21 ans donc je suis
un peu d'accord et colonnes je trouve
encore en plus scolaire c'est c'est
aussi sans doute un peu d'écoles kansas
oui moi je m'en cache pas je vois là je
suis très content du résultat du
deuxième tour si on en trouve mais
évidemment il faut aller suivre minette
comme plus tu vas aller lire les
articles du site et il faut les partager
au plus grand nombre puisque c'est de la
connaissance gratuite
on va passer aux questions twitter et
après si on a oublié des gens je peux
rajouter un détail vous formidable et
amusant sur le brent a alors si c'est
fait son demi-frère et le défenseur de
la ligue nationale de hockey
alors que sa mère dans un autre mayer si
vous google et tyler myers à la maison
il ne ressemble pas du tout
c'est absolument incroyable qui sont
qu'ils soient demi frère on voit que le
côté athlétique
la première question de nos amis sur
twitter était sûr gérer maillard
robinson heures on en a parlé
est-ce que vous pensez que max & his
name a une chance serait mobile et donc
max et inès cesse c'est max admas si
vous prononcez à la française sont non
je n'ai où est ce que vous allez
pourquoi ça se prononce comme ça donc
une idée du bois tabata que la personne
qui l'a baptisé je n'avais aucune idée
non plus un mystère
donc c'est un petit meneur et donc c'est
le leader technique de l'équipe qui a de
l'équipe cendrillon petite équipe
cendrillon à la march madness et la c ie
quoi ils sont et qu'ils s'étaient
classés numéro 15 ça veut dire que ici
il est moins bonne équipe sur le papier
du tournoi et au final battu numéro deux
au high stakes et numéro 7 floride a
donc deux sets consécutifs grâce entre
autres à max ait n'est ce donc qui a été
flamboyant qui va facilement au panier
qui shoote à 44% à 3 points sur huit
tentatives 90 % aux lancers francs
il a totalement dominé sa conférence est
ce que vous croyez alors j'imagine que
vous n'aviez pas beaucoup plus jouer
avant cette march madness ce que vous
croyez à un avenir en nba à la volée là
il fait 75 kg 75 kg je vois pas comment
il peut survivre au contact je n'avais
jamais vu avant et je vous dirais même
que je n'avais jamais entendu parler de
la ville apparemment et une saq très
influente dans le monde des familles
chrétiennes mais ouais
ouais ouais ouais
et honnêtement je crois que je crois que
qui sera juste pas capable de rivaliser
physiquement pas plus et pas le le 75 kg
le plus découpée et leila mois ci ouais
mais très douce actrice mais absolument
je l'avais vu une seule fois c'était
contre contre qui ils promettent contre
oklahoma state en début de saison je les
raisons pour agir
il avait fait un très bon match comme un
site avait gagné sur la fin mais moi je
pense que c'est un jour fait pour la
jeep et l'it très clairement pour le
championnat de turquie pour donner du
caviar à neutraliser [ __ ] on va le
voir où il va jouer en ligue lega
dramatique john and the joint les gars
griotique l'agresseur j'ai vu ça hier
c'est peut-être pas et s miss le
meilleur prospect cette équipe voulant
j'ai bien aimé qu'il y au bas nord le
cac40 qui chutait -7 47% à 3 points sur
l'année 88 % aux lancers francs
il fait 6 8 donc c'est peut-être pas la
nba pour lui puisqu'il est pas vraiment
un critique même s'il prend pas mal de
remous en revanche forcément un rôle
quelque part pour lui en a pas imposante
en dehors du gotha tu as quelque chose à
dire sur max 6 m quand j'ai un peu plus
jouer que vous je pense j'ai dû le voir
trois ou quatre fois cette année
enfin notamment après que jean dans la
rédaction nous essouffler une de ses
pairs face à sauf dakota site et donc le
petit adversité on a mis 42 points je
crois à 14 sur 20 tirs
enfin globalement sur la saison
régulière d'après ce que j'ai pu voir ce
que j'ai pu entendre surtout de mes
collègues c'est un mec qui est des coups
de chaud qui a tourné à près de 50%
tiercé il a fait une vraie grosse saison
et naïve baisse un peu il baisse de
régime forcément il ya le contrecoup sur
la march madness donc comme
comme benji imagine one day mais oui
c'est un joueur pour l'europe et pour
prendre des gros chèques dans le
championnat turc etc
il est très croyant visiblement
puisqu'il son high school c'était
jésuites dallas high school une question
tient continuer avec toi hugo on parle
dazaï amaury ça le fait de moins en
moins de doute
asa et robbie compte il se présentait je
passe tu as des infos projet pas j'ai
pas d'infos n'y a pas une rumeur
particulière et deuxième question
subsidiaire
est-ce qu'il a le niveau pour être
drafté or actuellement gelé nombre
plutôt non par contre un joueur qui
rentre le progression j'avais eu la
chance de le voir à paris quand il voit
ci avait débarque à l'insep à l'été 2010
non
et enfin les poches ou une mode ce qui a
été blessé mais enfin si je vous fais
avec yepes j'ai déjà pu voir que
techniquement c'est un certain niveau
très très très très haut et fort oui il
ya une vraie progression dont la lecture
du jeu lent compréhension en deux ans là
je dirais pas qu'il est encore prêt je
te verrais bien rester une année
en plus c'est un coach au coeur je vois
pas trop pourquoi il partirait surtout
quand même prochaine avec le départ de
mme aubry
pas de son frère le coup et vannes on
oublié sauf cataclysme andy je vous
crois pas une seule seconde
ça ce sera probablement la première
option foncière avec drew pettersson qui
devrait rester une nuit également que je
j'imagine que enfin s'il signe si on
fait un choix rationnel il ya une grande
chance pour lui d'avoir beaucoup de
tickets shoots et encore plus à montrer
donc je vois pas pourquoi il partirait
fahim oublie de mettre 806 kilos
il a été extrêmement impressionnant
contre kansas des tirs lui dans tous
leurs pas trois points
j'avais un peu les yeux car qui est tout
ça très mauvais pourcentage aux lancers
france ça vraiment de la chose à
travailler pour une
niveau du tir et sinon il est quand même
un peu plus costaud physiquement c'est
normal qu'un peu plus vieux que son
frère evan en tout cas sûr il ya des des
plus grosses cuisses il est plus ramassé
des nobles est plus longiligne avec plus
de facilité à bouger mais mais ça peut
aussi faire en 5 un peu plus
traditionnel qui s'écarte du côté d
avoir une question pour anne guillou
boeheim bedie brahim est ce que ça sent
le maître en draft qui cartonne ensuite
alors déjà ses quatre derniers matches
c'est du grand n'importe quoi votre
contextualiser c'est le shooter 2 3 aux
2/3 de l'équipe de syracuse le fils du
coach qui fait un mètre 98 et qui
majoritairement shoot
vas-y que je le sais deux derniers
matches au tournoi ici s'ils essaient de
prendre assuré march madness
il est quasiment à trois points de
moyenne mais mais c'est quand même un
mec qui est un 18 points de moyenne sur
l'année et 40% à 3 points sur huit
tentatives et 87 % aux lancers francs
donc c'est pas puisque c'est un gros
coup de chaud mais c'est quand même un
vrai joueur l'année dernière il était
déjà 37% à 3 points sur huit tentatives
par match donc c'est un shooteur c'est
un gros gros shooter en cause une chute
il peut shooter développement d'un ami
de trop virginia des choses très très
long le souci c'est que moi j'ai du mal
à l'évaluer défensivement parce que
c'est la zone quoi c'est toujours le mon
petit souci avec avec le genre de
circuit je me rappelle d'une saison de
andrew wight
oui je l'avais shooter incroyablement
d'anciens de kansas et nebraska et ça va
pas non plus trop faire une bière c'est
un très fort shooteur clinicienne et
c'était je pense que leurs meilleurs
athlètes que bunny game mais après quand
je shoote comme bobby brown tu peux
avoir des opportunités une personne
complètement mais en fait je suis même
pas sûr que c'est le meilleur prospect
syracuse ses meilleurs joueurs à l'heure
actuelle peut-être mais et d'autres
joueurs hyper intéressant dans cette
équipe et je pense que c'est surtout qui
va rester une quatrième année à la fac
avec son port avec des lits donc qui
devrait redonner sens que moi mr march
et et au miso le coach de michigan state
c'est son surnom c'est franchement petit
boy mail en train de faire une malakai
richardson - ouais il est coutumier du
fait syracuse sont là pour pourrir des
brackets est bon c'est bien à chaque
fois une question pour ben oui c'est
choisi parce que je viens la réponse est
non
c'est très très optimiste de les voir
[Musique]
regardez cameron crowe devait monter sur
le podium sert il faut savoir est ce que
les gens ont des difficultés à
comprendre avec je ne sais que les
joueurs de l'ange de craig et judi c'est
les hommes qui jouent souvent qu'on des
garçons c'est pour ça que les les
seniors performe comme ça ils ont
beaucoup plus de basket dans le corps
plus d'éducation ils ont vécu plus de
choses leur conte sont plus développés
c'est pour ça qu'ils donnent des raclées
comme soit spécialement d'outils mis que
jouer à gonzaga tout par endroits 80
puis qui comme qui a absolument été
exposé kid qui est déçu vraiment laissé
un qui se fait trop longtemps moi j'ai
l'impression que ça fait quatre ans
qu'ils jouent mais qui est exposé à un
basket magnifique à une
un partage du ballon à une créativité et
c'est pour ça que c'est joli ces joueurs
là sont supers fond nous avons très bien
à ma jeunesse mais non ils vont
peut-être être drafté il leur manque
beaucoup de leur manque beaucoup de fizi
qualités pour jouer dans la nba puis des
traces et ce qu'amène trouvé que ça
serait pas je la donne je trouve
absolument génial avec cette moustache
se serait pas ce serait pas un service à
lui rendre
elle met dans une raquette avec du
wallaby de quelque chose ce serait un
peu gâché le pivot de 2 louyot la
chicago qui est vraiment une super
équipe avoir jeu qui était peut-être le
meilleur match de cette marche c'est le
comme je les baptisés dans notre chat
whatsapp c'est le job de seyssel c'est
un poste qu'elle 5 qui est un peu
créateur mais qui shoote patrouille il a
vraiment beaucoup de toucher mais pour
les passes surtout les tirs de près il
pèse très lourd aussi il ya des l'ombre
à 116 kg et de route ibis est le pivot
de gonzaga que vous allez certainement
voir au final fort et qui est dominent
assez souvent son adversaire direct dans
la raquette on aimerait beaucoup voir
opposer à evans moblie évidemment si on
va gagner leur prochain match on a
encore encore une question avant de
rendre l'antenne com que pensez-vous
hugo de mosey ce midi je peux si tu l'as
vu
attention c'est à dire non organiques et
surtout didier chenet j'adore j'adore le
joueur je pense que c'est c'est déjà
malgré son jeune âge des meilleurs
joueurs de son équipe
enfin oui c'est un trait encore une fois
un très beau joueur voir jouer ces
compléments capable de marquer beaucoup
de beaux coups de poing de prendre deux
rebonds donc je lui c'est quelqu'un que
je doive très beau un prochain concours
des postes
tout post 2 to
je pense qu'ils jouent aux billes et
quand il ira même s'il a la taille pour
descendre des postes de 3 puisqu'il ya
98 il s'est déjà 93 kg - ouais il est
plutôt il est plutôt il ressemble plus à
un produit fini que la part des frais
chaîne seulement mais s'il l'est moi je
crois pas je crois pas que c'est un
produit fini je crois qu'il est déjà
interdite il est trop jeune qui est déjà
trop et du cayla certains aspects du jeu
pourra être un choix du cinéma je crois
qu'il ya des belles surprises à voir
avec les bons catch and shoot il est bon
à trois points je crois qu'il ya des
belles surprises à moi je crois qu'il va
être la montée des flashs de création
pour lui-même je crois que le potentiel
de surprise agréable pour lui il met
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de pression
sur l'adversaire
les gens qui ont je joue et que je joue
au basket une couette savent un joueur
qui va à 200 milles à l'heure quand tu
joues c'est absolument infernal
affronter et ça c'est beau ce mobile et
le potentiel de surprise désagréable est
assez faible aussi à l'année la question
subsidiaire et en hesse qui peut emmener
son équipe au style fort c'est à dire
qu'il faut battre la fabuleuse équipe
doral roberts d'abord et ensuite le
vainqueur de paix lors que la nova
alors ma prédiction était que baylor
jouerait arkansas aux states et je pense
que ça va être compliqué en fait le
match qu'on texas tech moi ça ne m'a pas
rassuré personnel le premier match le
deuxième match 2 2 au match pour
arkansas
il m'a pas rassuré parce que même si
j'aime bien texas tech son équipe
chiante à jouer que je suis amoureux de
terrain de shannon s'est pas non plus je
trouve cette année la meilleure équipe
de textes et qu'on ait eue et une énorme
cylindre est ancien et franchement il
aurait vraiment pu sortir dans ce match
vraiment c'est une équipe jeune on est
passé souvent en avant dont on parle
beaucoup des équipes qui dédiez
oakenshield jackie star beaucoup de
freshman ya trois freshman qui sont
situées à arkansas
il ya un secteur intérieur avec deux
joueurs mais le genre qui prend pas mal
de fautes
jay leno vous dire parce que moi j'aime
bien leur espèce de trou de freshman
mimétisme ou asiatique là et que ça avec
sa touche et aussi le transfuge de
indiana son nom mais ça doit être ça
doit être multi styles smith ouais c'est
ça qui prennent pas mal de fautes et je
pense que ça peut être un peu compliquée
s'ils se font attaquer ciblées sur des
ciseaux parler butler les tig et et
compagnie je pense qu'ils iront à
l'emirates je reviens avoir maudit en
fait défendre mais les wc 3 les trois
petits de baylor parce qu'en fait le
seul tout ce que j'ai sur lui je pense
que c'est un joueur qui est son profil
défensif il est super mais il était trop
petit ou légèrement surévalué sur ses
capacités à défendre les plus petits
parce que je ne trouve pas hyper véloce
latéralement et tout ça je pense qu'en
fait c'est surtout un super joueur
d'équipé parfait role player ils auront
besoin de prendre un peu tous feux à
côté levé pour pour battre dès lors
c'est simon qui aura besoin de smith du
petit djédjé dit nono teil en sortie de
banc et puis de déshonneur de l'équipe
il y avait une autre question je vais
faire rapidement si vous avez la réponse
ou dit top aurait la main côté michigan
a par wagner et dickinson qui d'autre a
le potentiel pour jouer en nba
moi j'ai toujours le way vrai mais qui
malheureusement out
il ya deux transfuges de wake cas n'est
pas mal de points shaun deeb la jon
diebler peut-être pas mais il a le
physique en tout cas le physique et
enfin ça c'est plus dur puisque il ya
des joueurs que vous allez monter ou
descendre de march madness
c'est soit que du zinc et des métaux
mais moi ça m'a donné plus en fait plus
que monter ce jeu john lynch heures dans
un podcast donc un procès avec memphis
aridi qu'en fait les équipes elles ont
souvent leur board de faire rien ne
change vraiment la marche mais ce qui
change c'est que tu peux voir une
performance d'un gars et au lieu de
juger ce garçon apparemment ça n'a envie
d'aller revoir du film sur lui oui et
moi c'est ce que je vais faire sur
quelques jours notamment aaron wiggins
de marie dans l'art il absolument mari
en fait c'est plus ça qui va rien faire
changer prophète chez les joueurs que
j'ai pas vu pas assez vu il faut une
grosse perf à la march madness
du coup je vais aller me refaire des
matchs de saison régulière parce que
pour un plein bourg échantillons c'est
plus ça en fait absolument 1 messieurs
est ce que votre champion national
bracket est toujours en cours oui oui
moi j'avais bel oui oui moi j'ai jamais
de braquer une journée en objet us in
may d'aujourd'hui on s'entend course
parfait et soit alex
moi aussi j'ai des goûts saga en finale
compte baylor parce que j'ai envie de
voir ce match
moi j'ai mon généraliste mon finalistes
n'est plus là malheureusement j'avais
livre mon fils
c'est toujours si houston c'est
ambitieux saison je ne peux pas je ne
peux pas maintenant mais ils ont une
région qui s'est dégagé une qui s'est
ouverte way et vont se prendre un
barrage à trois points sur la pelouse
zone regarder conseille de regarder
scheiben marque notamment du côté du
stade des prospects probablement le
joueur le plus intéressant avec giorgio
ouais voilà on vous reparlera march
madness plus tard mais en tout cas on a
fait un peu le le tour de ses joueurs
qui nous ont agréablement surpris et qui
voilà qui peuvent nous sauter aux yeux
et nous donner envie comme disait alan
c'était pas mal comme conclusion de
revoir du film est de retrouver
certaines qualités ou pas de voir si
c'était juste un coup de chaud ou et si
vraiment il quelque chose tiens c'est
chez ce joueur en particulier
hugo merci beaucoup merci à vous merci
hugo c'est est ce que ton prochain
article
alors l'explosivité alors j'avais le
projet je sais pas si j'aurai le temps
dans cette semaine mais je vais essayer
de faire le maximum de 1 à miser faire
une analyse vidéo de la défaite des
nourrices et pourquoi browser or use a
du sang sur les mains j'aborde
effectivement intéressant c'est un très
beau match on a fait 9
oyonnax chicago à l'année ben évidemment
merci et à bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures sur envergure merci à vous de
nous avoir écoutés pour vous redirige
vers aussi quand wenger penser aux
et on fait des bisous ciao